ce soir notre performance sera assurée
par manu payet manu payet a au splendid
un triomphe un million de représentation
du mardi au samedi 20 heures spectacle
produit par dominique farrugia manu
payet bonsoir alors tranches ont un
problème franco français dit-on payet ou
payet je me suis disputé avec la moitié
de la terre le sujet et paillettes c'est
payet as well as oui parce que je suis
réunionnais voilà vous êtes réunionnais
alors que c'était un enfant de la radio
nrj nrj là-bas énergie en france avec un
mentor le folin avec sébastien folin et
puis dominique farrugia et puis ensuite
la rencontre avec dominique farrugia
ouais c'est vrai qui a qui a été pour
moi
un gros changement parce que lorsque
dominique m'a proposé d'émissions de
télé je lui ai dit j'aimerais bien
dominique
aussi parce que je suis en train
d'écrire un spectacle avec un garçon qui
s'appelle fils-aimé slash et j'aimerais
bien que tu produis ce spectacle te
plaît parce que c'est tout ce qui nous
manque on a un texte vous à lens ou
d'accord alors qu'est ce qu'on va
trouver dans ce spectacle quelque chose
qui est comme entre en relation avec vos
origines réunionnaises parce que vous
avez une famille dont vous dites ma
famille elle a été faite uniquement pour
que j'écrive un spectacle dansé
qu'est-ce qu'on tombe dans votre celui
bas parce que j'ai des parents originaux
j'ai des parents que qui qui m'ont
inspiré énormément parce que j'ai une
maman qui qui n'est fier de moi que
parce que je sais conduire dans paris
correctement place de l'étoile
place de l'étoile ça elle adore quand je
la prends avec elle crée dans la voiture
elle est super fier de moi alors là
non c'est je suis son fils elle le
raconte à toute la réunion quand elle
rentre à la maison on retrouve aussi vos
origines groupe de rock de lycée en
jouant les cancres qui arrivait en
retard aux cours d'anglais c'est ça
ouais une belle chanson ya une belle
chanson j'avais vraiment ce groupe de
rock s'appelait evry late avril est
toujours en retard il est toujours en
retard parce qu'on était toujours en
retard et surtout très nuls en anglais
et avec ce groupe de rock on a essayé de
devenir des rock stars et puis ça s'est
pas fait parce pour plusieurs raisons et
notamment une réseau de talent je crois
qu'en savons que ça gêne n'est pas là on
n'avait pas le talent nécessaire pour
devenir la première à oui biensur bien
sûr bien sûr
alors ce qu'on trouve aussi c'est que
quand on verra unionais on a et qu'on
vient en france bon il ya quelques
surprises sur nos policiers les fameux
taser et le taser donner une appellation
que je trouve jolie oui et c'est l'âme
que donc inventé par les américains qui
ont expliqué qu'ils avaient réussir à
inventer une chaise électrique de voyage
voilà qu'est ce que vous allez nous
proposer ce soir
bah écoutez je vais déjà vous proposer
de réussir à monter sur ce banc et je
vous cache pas que ça fait partie de mes
angoisses lui on va vous rassurer vous
allez voir on a un public fort
sympathique agréable et accueillant
alors allez comme on allait monta au
montât ou voilà si sûr et manu payet as
bonsoir ça avant cela merci beaucoup
il ya une histoire qui est sur la
sécurité qui fait que nous on flippe
tous un petit peu parce qu'on est
tellement conditionnés au regard des
reportages à la télé sur la sécurité la
menace des banlieues le danger concours
quand on sort de chez nous qui fait que
ça nous rend tous un peu parano et moi
je pense qu'il faut arrêter avec tout ça
parce que tous ces mecs qui nous
bassinent etc la sécurité c'est les
mêmes mecs qui disent que la france
était mû à 50 ans que les rues étaient
plus sûr que les jeunes étaient plus
polis qui avait pas de tags sur les murs
alors que les tags quand tu regardes
bien c'est c'est vieux comme le monde
ça date de la préhistoire à l'époque
dans la grotte les mecs qui peignait sur
les murs étaient déjà des tags
d'ailleurs si ça se trouve un buffle à
mammoth une main ça voulait dire nique
la police pour n'en sais rien moi je
suis fasciné par ces peuples la
préhistoire parce que c'est l'époque à
laquelle tout aller beaucoup plus vite
mais qu'il n'avait pas de temps à perdre
je suis fasciné parce que à l'époque
l'espérance de vie c'était 16 ans
fallait que ça speed la vie est passé
comme ça les gars y dormaient dix
minutes par l'upa plus les bébés une
heure après l'accouchement et partez à
la chasse
à 8 ans tu faisais tu as crise de la
trentaine 6 à 10 ans tu étais pas marié
était pas de ghost était considéré comme
un mec très louche dans la grotte patois
perles aviez passé comme ça tu vas créer
j'ai 15 ans j'ai bien vécu dit merci
mais là je sens que c'est la fin il ya
des signes qui ne trompent pas la petite
moustache des boutons sur la gueule tout
ça j'en ai plus pour longtemps
avant ça va la vérité j'ai fait une
belle vie j'ai une mariée mon fils de 8
ans attention gros mariage on avait loué
la grotte du pré catelan
il était sapé de folie costumes en peau
de koga sur mesure le fait de mammouth à
volonté ils ont bouffé comme des manches
il y avait du guest de partout du people
c'est qu'ici qui est passé à la fin or
il est resté cinq minutes mais pour les
gosses est toujours actif
qu est-ce qu on s'est marré [ __ ] et
des chabal je suis fasciné par cette
période de la préhistoire parce que
vraiment tout devait beaucoup speed et
je suis facile et aussi parce que je
suis en train de faire quand même un
truc qui vient de l'espace et ça aurait
peut-être dû marcher sur tatooine ou
mais il a fallu que pour faire des
choses comme celles là ce soir j'ai eu
un déclic dans ma vie et j'ai eu ce
déclic ya pas très longtemps pour
commencer un spectacle sur scène en
regardant un reportage à la télé sur la
cornemuse et je me suis dit si un
instrument aussi improbable a fonctionné
je peux monter sur scène phare one man
show
rendez vous compte quand même qu'il ya
un mec super longtemps en écosse qui a
inventé la cornemuse qu'est ce qu'être
plus bizarre qu une cornemuse
je pense qu'on est tous d'accord pour
dire toute façon il est plus là pour en
parler que ce gars est un malade mental
rien y en avoir une idée là on va
zigouiller cette brebis
on va prendre ça pense et on va souffler
dedans
enfin mac allister tu as pété les plombs
et ça a marché ça a fonctionné la
cornemuse est né ce soir là vingt
minutes après ce même gardien avec un
autre délire 2ème idées et les gares à
chaque fois qu'on va jouer de ce truc
on va retirer nos slips et on va se
[ __ ] en gip
voilà c'est comme ça que j'ai eu mon
déclic et j'ai décidé monter sur scène
au splendid du mardi au samedi à 20h
merci beaucoup bonsoir et boissons
[Musique]